I believe that Humanity's original wound
is that we saw ourselves separate from
nature we've defined nature that way
even minerals plants animals everything
except humans or things humans have made
really I believe we are the greatest
technology expressed by Nature so far
why did we discover and develop the
electron microscope
why did we make the Hubble telescope
it's a spiritual experience is better
than any Cathedral Lifest ever stepped
into is looking at the beauty through
human eyes of the cosmos
and in the microscope looking at the
beauty of a single cell and so was our
technological Journey ultimately
to supercharge our Five Senses Into
seeing the full beauty of this planet so
that everything would change the very
matrix by which we live breathe think
and imagine within is here to shift in
this moment if we really see the
universe for all its beauty it will
switch completely every atom will change